monsieur baumel grosse déception ce soir
oui bien sûr beaucoup de déception
beaucoup déception parce que on avait
fait une belle campagne avec beaucoup de
militants qui sont encore ici présents
et et beaucoup d'amis de caupenne
camarades avec qui on ferraille depuis
de longues années déjà pour essayer de
porter un certain nombre d'idées et qui
n'ont pas été entendus vous payez le
pratique est là ce soir ps je ne sais
pas si je paye cette étiquette là je
paye la division de la gauche oui c'est
incontestablement parce qu'il y avait
une multitude de candidats de gauche et
quand je vois que finalement je
n'accepte pas au deuxième tour parce
qu'il me manque quelques centaines de
voix c'est à dire un peu plus un peu
moins de 400 voix en vérité ça veut dire
qu'il y avait eu moins de division
j'aurais pu y être
voilà ça je pense que je paye ça d'abord
et puis je paye aussi beaucoup de
confusion la confusion générée par
l'élection présidentielle avec un
candidat qui se dit ni droite ni gauche
et finalement qui crée une espèce de
nappes de fumée sur la géographie
politique du pays et qui laisse à penser
que finalement il incarnerait peut être
l'espoir parce que parce que tout ça
personne ne sait finalement qu'est-ce
qu'il va promouvoir dans les mois et les
années à venir on le devine un peu mais
il faut regarder de près mais voilà l'un
des élections législatives étant jumelée
avec la présidentielle tout ça bien très
vite et on est dans l'état de grâce donc
il ya un certain nombre de français qui
ne réagissent pas et la preuve en est
aussi puisque malheureusement il ya eu
aussi beaucoup d'abstention dans cette
circonscription
on la sait les trois fait cumuler à mon
avis qui donne larchitecture de ce vote
qui est un vote je crois qu'ils ne
portent pas l'avenir